The Joe Rogan Experience ah well
throughout my career was there anything
that I would change yeah well I we'll
get into this topic I guess
um after I broke my neck the second time
the first time in WWE I was introduced
to painkillers and um
uh when I started taking them I really
liked it I mean it it masked the pain I
couldn't feel the pain it kind of gave
me an energetic feel it didn't make me
feel nauseous like it does a lot of
people and I started taking I was taking
one every four to six hours like I was
told but after a while you build a
tolerance and one doesn't work anymore
then you have to take two then two led
to four four
this was extra strength Vicodin
oxycontins are a lot more powerful than
Vicodin but I was taking 65 extra drinks
like it in a day whoa that's how out of
control I got and I was hiding it from
the company
and and I mean it was I was in serious
trouble and does that even make you high
at that point does it just keep you from
going in okay withdrawals it kept me
from going through withdrawals but there
were times where I passed out I mean the
company knew
um some of my friends knew
um you know I'll give you an example I I
um there was one point that this is how
how bad it got
um there was one point in my career
where uh I uh
my brother called me I was at a house
showing on televise show for WWE was the
night before I was gonna have the
biggest match of my career with Brock
Lesnar the next day it was an Iron Man
match on Smackdown and um my brother
calls me and says hey your sister just
out of a heroin overdose
and it it crushed me I mean I I was I
was crying I was in such pain thinking
about my sister who was only 40 years
old dying from heroin overdose and the
thing is I wasn't able to talk to her
because I told her eight months prior if
she doesn't get clean I'm gonna
um I'm not gonna talk to you so I didn't
talk to her for eight months and then
this happens
and I was so here I am I'm in the hotel
room
and I look at my pills
I said [__] it I took 20 of them threw
them in my mouth chewed them up and
swallowed them oh my God I didn't wake
up till five o'clock in the afternoon
the next day and I had the biggest match
in my career oh my God so what time did
you have to be to the arena and did you
do it you had to be there at one but I
didn't get there until 5 30. right yeah
but um yeah I ended up doing it the wlb
was trying to call me the whole time
they were like they wanted to tell me
that hey you can go home plan a funeral
for your sister you don't have to do
this match but I kept thinking I know my
sister would want me to and and and I
knew that I I wouldn't have to feel that
pain of losing my sister at least for
that hour yeah so I I went ahead and did
it and it was actually one of my best
performances of my career which is kind
of crazy but uh that was that was a
really rough time and the painkillers
are the one thing that I do regret I did
in the company I wish I was never
introduced to them but do you think you
had to take them I mean it sounds like
you were in such excruciating pain all
the time there were times I needed take
them and there were times I didn't but I
was so far deep into it that I had to I
mean I'm not gonna lie to you I would go
to sleep at night I would have 15 pills
sitting on the desk next to me for when
I wake up because I knew I was gonna
have withdrawal when I got up I wake up
sweating shaking and I grabbed those
throw them in my mouth chew them up and
swim 15 at a time 15 at a time
wow
wow yeah most people 15 at a time will
kill you well it didn't show me I you
know I took 20 at one time when my
sister died so I've been really lucky
I've been blessed I I honestly I don't
think I should be here today how'd you
get off of them
okay uh well what happened was I left
the WWE because they wanted me to go to
rehab but I don't want to go so I ended
up going to another company called
Impact Wrestling and I I got my
painkiller problem under control there
because I got I found a doctor that got
me on MS Contin there are two
um
morphine pills they're very tiny but
they'll keep you from going through
withdrawal so I would take one in the
morning one at night and no more
painkillers they were pain killers
because they were morphine but they were
high dose it was just two of them that I
had to take well I started having
anxiety about breaking my neck over and
over again so they put me on Xanax so
now I'm taking Xanax and then I switched
to TNA Impact Wrestling and everybody
drank there so I started drinking
alcohol so I'm mixing having these
cocktails and I'm I'm so out of control
that I'm driving okay from town to town
drinking a 12 pack of beer and I got
four DUIs in five years I lost my
reputation everything I worked for I was
at lowest point in my life and uh I
remember calling my wife from jail after
my fourth DUI and she said listen I
can't do this anymore you either go to
rehab or I'm taking the kids and I'm
leaving and I so I went to rehab because
I want to lose my wife and my kids and I
was scared in rehab I I literally
thought I was so nervous the first of
all the withdrawal was the worst
experience I ever had I'll never go
through that again because I'm never
going to take another painkiller that
was the worst thing I've ever done or
drink another drop of alcohol that was
the absolute worst thing I've ever been
through and I forget what I was going to
say though but so with the rehab do they
how do they get you off of it they don't
do it cold turkey right do you think
they do yes they do I thought they were
going to wee me off
they put you in a room and let you sleep
and they check on you every couple hours
and uh about six days for me to go
through the withdrawal symptoms it
seemed like forever
is you just in a room by yourself yeah
just thinking yeah and you know what and
you want to stay in there and they they
start forcing you out you got you got to
come move around you got to come out and
talk to people you gotta you know live
your life and you don't you you're so
exhausted for the first two and a half
weeks I didn't want to move I just want
to stay in my bed but they were forcing
me to get out of bed and and be in a
Converse Converse or conversating with
people and trying to you know go and eat
and go to meetings and do all that stuff
you do in rehab so it was it was really
tough how long did it take before you
felt normal
um well I would say two weeks where I
really felt normal but the the thing is
the last two weeks because I spent a
month in rehab the last two weeks I was
so nervous that I was gonna [__] up
again like I I literally didn't want to
leave rehab I was scared that I was
going to go back to it right when I got
out so many guys do you know that's why
like I hear all these stories and I'm
like oh it's gonna happen to you too man
and uh you know but but the one thing
that I kept going across in my mind was
going through withdrawal I don't want to
do that again and I know if I start
taking them I'm going to have to
experience that again and I don't want
to it was that bad it was that bad what
is it like like what is the control feel
like okay you're sweating because you're
hot and you're cold at the same time
you're [__] your pants you're
throwing up
um uh you can't think straight your
body's shaking uh you're you're getting
hot sweats cold sweats uh everything's
you feel like you don't have anything
inside to you no insides no organs
nothing you feel like you're Hollow it's
just the craziest thing it's the most
painful thing I've ever gone through and
you know I'm sure people have been in a
lot more pain than that with certain
things they've had done to themselves
but uh for me that was the worst